[Musik]
es ist einer der spektakulärsten
kunstdiebstähle der ddr geschichte der
raub des sogenannten sophien schatzes
reist eine wunde ins kunsthistorische
herz der stadt dresden eine wunde die
bis heute nicht ganz verheilt ist
zwanzigster september
1977 friedrich reichardt damals 28
arbeitet als historiker im stadtmuseum
auch nach 45 jahren ist die erinnerung
an jenen tag lebendig
also an diesem tag hatte an dem
nachmittag zwei gruppen die gast der
pädagogischen hochschule in dresden war
und zwar deutsch
angehende deutschlehrerin aus wolgograd
im obersten stockwerk möchte er ihnen
die glanzstücke des museums zeigen
darunter zahlreiche äußerst wertvolle
grabbeigaben aus den gerüchten der
sophienkirche den sogenannten sophien
schatz plötzlich rief die betreuerin von
der pädagogischen hochschule ja stimmt
irgendetwas nicht
ich bin dann dorthin und später sagten
dann die teilnehmer der einige
teilnehmer der führung der mann wurde
ganz blass und sagt dass es ungefähr die
hälfte der betriebe ausgeräumt war
[Musik]
es ist ein schock müssen die diebe doch
am hellichten tag zugeschlagen haben
57 schmuckgegenstände fehlen ketten
ringe armbänder vor jahrhunderten
gefertigt und getragen ein verlust der
in geld nur schwer zu beziffern ist
in der presseberichterstattung in den
1970 er jahren wurde von mehreren
millionen mark ddr mark damals
gesprochen es lässt sich allerdings sehr
schwer genau taxieren aus dem einfachen
grund man kann ja nicht den einfachen
materialwert angeben natürlich könnten
wir das jetzt ausrechnen wie viel gold
anteil ist dabei gewesen wie viele
edelsteine und das -hoch kalkulieren
allerdings ist der materialwert von dem
entfernt was das kulturhistorisch für
eine bedeutung hat friedrich reichardt
lässt damals das haus sofort abriegeln
und ruft die polizei bald wimmelt es von
beamten die ermittlungen aufnehmen es
folgen stundenlange befragungen besucher
mitarbeiter passanten am ende werden es
3600 personen sein die befragt wurden
auch die spurensicherung nimmt ihre
arbeit auf
man stellte fest es gab eine kamera hier
oben die auf die widrigen gerichte fort
die wir verstellt die betriebe selbst
phase aus sandstein gemauert mit
panzerglas und stellte es überaus das in
geschlossene schwachstelle warum also
dran gekommen
von den dieben und ihrer wertvollen
beute fehlt jede spur
auf ein zeugenaufruf in der zeitung und
berichte im ddr fernsehen bringen die
ermittler nicht weiter letztendlich wird
das verfahren nach mehreren monaten
eingestellt die kunstschätze scheinen
verloren
bis
1986 neun jahre nach dem raub in dresden
in einem hamburger auktionshaus ein
goldener anhänger angeboten wird
es ist eine eckige münster eine
sogenannte klippe der sächsischen
kurfürsten magdalena sibylla
einfach weg doch dann ein jahr später
bekommt die kölner staatsanwaltschaft
ein paket darin die clips
vergehen aber noch weitere 13 jahre bis
der akte so viel schutz ein weiteres
kapitel hinzugefügt wird unerwartet und
überraschend tauchen gleich mehrere
stücke auf dem kunstmarkt auf die
geschichte des großen volkes beginnt am
27 2000 und da findet ein münzhändler
in einem aktions und
messeangebot einer fachmesse einen
hinweis auf diesen konvolut von
38 stücken
angeboten werden sie von einem
münzhändler aus oslo und so reisen nur
einen monat nach der entdeckung
kriminalbeamte und die vize direktorin
des stadtmuseums in die norwegische
hauptstadt gemeinsam mit der dortigen
polizei suchen sie das geschäft des
händlers auf und fordern die herausgabe
der schmuckstücke
darum
und er
si
nach mehr als zwei jahrzehnten tauchen
die schon verloren geglaubten
schmuckstücke wieder auf
[Musik]
gleichzeitig mit ihnen aber auch die
frage wer waren die täter doch
unterlagen über den ankauf des schmucks
existieren nicht mehr da die
aufbewahrungsfrist abgelaufen ist der
osloer händler behauptet er habe die
stücke 17 jahre zuvor in kopenhagen
erworben angeblich nicht wissend dass
ist diebesgut war diese quelle die man
hier auch noch hätte fragen können
nämlich dem center in kopenhagen
war leider nicht mehr so befragen weil
er verstorben war schon wein 18
und wieder verliert sich die spur nach
den dieben aber
wenigstens die 38 in oslo gefundenen
schmuckstücke kehren 2005 nach
langwierigen verhandlungen zurück nach
dresden
es war der wohl größte kunstraub in der
ddr die genauen umstände dieses kurs
sind noch immer nicht völlig aufgeklärt
aber das wichtigste die schmuckstücke
sind wieder aufgetaucht
mit sichtlichem stolz präsentiert der
damalige oberbürgermeister der
sächsischen landeshauptstadt die
heimkehrer
ich kann mich dann natürlich sehr genau
erinnern uns war einfach es war schon
irgendwie bewältigen
plötzlich ist wieder etwas da was
verloren ist und noch zwei weitere
einzelstücke finden ihren weg zurück ins
stadtmuseum das letzte erst 2017 40
jahre nach dem diebstahl
es ergab sich tatsächlich zufällig denn
es war ein sammler verstorben seine frau
löste die sammlung auf und ein
auktionshaus dass sie heben mit dem
verkauf beauftragt hatte trat in kontakt
mit den staatlichen kunstsammlungen und
die aufmerksamen kolleginnen und
kollegen informierten wiederum uns als
stadtmuseum woher der sammler das stück
hatte musste die witwe nicht und wieder
liefen die ermittlungen ins leere der
dreister raub des sogenannten sophien
schatzes er bleibt ein rätsel nach
nunmehr 45 jahren schwindet zwar die
hoffnung die täter zu finden nicht aber
die hoffnung dass die letzten 16 immer
noch verschollenen schmuckstücke
irgendwann zurückkehren in die sammlung
des dresdner stadtmuseums